all men dream but not equally those who
dream by night in the dusty recesses of
their minds wake in the day to find that
it was vanity but the dreamers of the
day are dangerous men for they may act
their dreams with open eyes to make it
possible
this i did when the life story of
british colonel thomas edward lawrence
made it to the silver screen in 1962
under the direction of david lean
starring peter o'toole as the main
character it was hailed as one of the
greatest movies ever made a prestigious
reputation which it still holds to this
day what about the real person behind
the movie today we explore the story of
the man who went to war and became known
as lawrence of arabia
thomas edward lawrence was born on
august 16th 1888 in the village of
tremedog in north wales he was the
second son of sir thomas chapman's
seventh baronet who was born out of
wetlock after his father left his wife
and four daughters and ran away with the
governor sarah jonah when sarah became
pregnant the couple fled ireland where
chapman lived with his first family and
relocated to wales where they adopted
the surname lawrence and soon gave birth
to their first son afterwards came
thomas or ned as the family called him
followed by three other sons although
the couple never married because chapman
never attempted to divorce his wife
young ned lived a nomadic lifestyle for
most of his early childhood as the
family moved around from place to place
until 1896 when they finally settled in
oxford that was where he went to school
and also attended an anglican youth
organization called the church lads
brigade at the insistence of his devout
mother she hoped that her sons would
follow the same kind of holy cooling in
life but this didn't really jive with
ned's budding thirst for learning an
adventure tensions between mother and
son steadily rose as the years went on
sometime during his childhood ned found
out about his parents sword it passed
and that he and his four brothers were
all illegitimate but he never attempted
to confront his parents over it or make
contact with his step siblings lawrence
claimed his relationship with his mother
was at its worst in 1905 when he ran
away from home and enlisted as a boy
soldier in the army until his father
showed up and bought him out of the
service however historians have not been
able to find any records of this
happening so either the army wasn't very
thorough when it came to keeping tabs on
new recruits or lawrence was
a bit prone to exaggeration as you'll
soon find out this wasn't lawrence's
only claim that has been brought under
scrutiny either way ned found himself
back home again but he gained a modicum
of independence when his parents agreed
to build him a bungalow at the end of
the garden where he had some privacy and
was free to pursue his interests it soon
became pretty evident that church was
not one of them instead he developed a
taste for studying the past but he
preferred to get his dose of history
alfresco going out in the field instead
of sticking his nose in dusty old books
he became a keen cyclist who liked to
travel to castles and churches all over
the country to take photographs and
brass rubbings he took up cycling partly
as a way of making up for his small
stature unlike the lofty physique of
actor peter o'toole the real lawrence
was only five foot five and had quite a
big head for his size he felt pretty
self-conscious about this his entire
life which is why he always was looking
to build up his strength in order to
compensate another way he kept fit was
by avoiding all alcohol tobacco and meat
although he occasionally indulged in
them whenever he wanted to abide by
local customs when ned ran out of
castles to study in britain he traveled
to france for two summers in order to
see what they had to offer in the summer
of 1909 the 20 year old lawrence
embarked on his most ambitious adventure
yet he went on a walking tour of the
crusader castles in syria which back
then was mostly part of the ottoman
empire he walked over 1 600 kilometers
during a three-month period receiving
first-hand exposure to the arabic
culture that would define his entire
legacy
[Music]
when lawrence wasn't bicycling his way
from castle to castle he was studying
medieval history at jesus college oxford
he used the material and information he
obtained in ottoman syria to write his
thesis and he graduated with first class
honours in 1910. now that he was
finished with school lawrence needed a
career ideally something that combined
historical studies with the exploration
of landmarks in far away locations the
choice seemed pretty obvious with his
parents full support lawrence became a
quantity surveillance i
became an archaeologist in 1911 he
already had his first gig lined up
thanks to his mentor british scholar
david george hogarth as an established
archaeologist hogarth was in charge of
an expedition to carcamice set up by the
british museum and he took lawrence
along with the ride located today on the
border between syria and turkey kakamish
was once an ancient settlement that
acted both as an independent city-state
and an important part of the hittite
empire hogarth and his team spent the
next three years excavating in the
region allowing laurens to witness
first-hand the struggles present in the
region he formed a close friendship with
a young arab boy named dahum who then
served as assistant and traveling
companion somewhat fittingly his team's
biggest rival in the area wasn't any of
the locals but rather the germans who
were there building a railroad and kept
butting heads with the english over land
access at the start of 1914 tensions
between nations were at an all-time high
as war loomed over the world lawrence
was given a new assignment to explore
the negeb desert ostensibly he was doing
this at the behest of a british
archaeological society called the
palestine exploration fund trying to
find a biblical location named the
wilderness of zin in reality though this
was basically a spy mission as the
project was a smoke screen staged by the
british military to allow lawrence and
his team to survey the negev desert and
map out important features such as safe
routes water sources etc this
information was considered of great
strategic importance should war break
out and of course as we all know war
absolutely did break out lawrence was
back in england at the start of the
first world war he was keen to join in
but wasn't really sure where exactly his
talents would be best employed his
uncertainty was resolved in the fall of
1914 when two important things happened
one the ottoman empire officially joined
the war and 2 britain deposed the
egyptian leader abbas ii due to his
ottoman sympathies and declared egypt a
british protectorate shortly thereafter
lawrence was summoned to work for a
newly formed intelligence unit
headquartered in cairo named the arab
bureau as it turned out lawrence was
good at his job he understood the
history and the problems of the arabs he
spoke their language fluently and most
of all he had a genuine interest in
their fate in his mind the ideal outcome
would have been for the arab people to
gain a true independence that allowed
them to retain their identity and their
culture this wasn't necessarily the
vision shared by the british government
which was mainly looking after its own
interests but it wasn't completely
against it either obviously the worst
case scenario was for the ottoman empire
to retain its hold over the arab people
and maintain its dominion in the region
another unfavorable outcome as far as
the british officers at the arab era
were concerned was for france to gain
concessions in the area following a
victory in the war sure france was their
ally but the feud between the two
nations was a rivalry as old as time so
while they needed france to win they
didn't want it to win too much of course
lawrence had no idea at the time that
britain and france were already
discussing a secret treaty known as the
sykes-picot agreement to divide their
spheres of influence in the region after
the war therefore lawrence and his
colleagues were busy dealing with
intelligence and propaganda against
their own ally in order to in his own
words biff the french out of all hope of
syria the biggest downside to lawrence's
job was that it was done mainly behind a
desk sure he had no military training
but he was still eager to get out there
and see some action some have speculated
that he felt survivor's guilt because he
had a safe cushy job during the war
while two of his brothers died in 1915
fighting on the western front which was
why he acted so reckless once he was
actually out in the field true or not
lawrence would soon get his wish he
might have spent all of 1915 as a pencil
pusher but the following year would take
a drastic turn
in june 1916 the great arab revolt
started a military uprising of the arab
forces united against their common enemy
the ottoman empire the leader of this
army was hussein bin ali a member of the
hashemite royal family and the grand
sheriff of america as well as the king
of the newly proclaimed hashemite
kingdom of jazz the british government
played an important role as it not only
promised to supply the arabs with
weapons but also to recognize the single
unified arab state that would emerge if
they defeated the ottoman empire with
that much skin in the game the british
were not just going to sit back and hope
for the best they wanted their own men
to work closely with the arab forces
that's where t lawrence came in by
october of that year the sheriffian army
of king hussein had achieved some
initial success but their resolve and
morale had began to falter as the enemy
still had strategic numeric and military
superiority lawrence was sent in on a
fact-finding mission to gather
intelligence about how the war effort
was going and from this point on you
know most of what happens if you've seen
the movie first he met with all of king
hussein's sons the sharif was already in
his 60s by that point so he wasn't going
to be the one leading boots on the
ground lawrence concluded that prince
faisal would be the one best suited to
lead the revolt following their little
tether that lawrence sent a glowing
report back to headquarters which not
only commended the efforts of the arab
army but also discouraged the need for
british troops this might have not been
entirely accurate but it was music to
the ears of his superiors who wanted
those soldiers for other front lines and
consequently faisal asked for lawrence
to be assigned to him permanently as a
liaison officer a request which was
granted and thus
lawrence of arabia was born lawrence
advised faizal to delay his attempt to
capture medina in favor of strengthening
arab-controlled cities such as yanbu and
jedar while at the same time carrying
out regular raids on the hijaz railway
that traveled from damascus to medina in
order to disturb turkish supply lines
strategically it was sound but not
exactly thrilling how about a new plan
with some chest hair a plan that was
dangerous and reckless not to mention
that it went against the wishes of the
british government to plans such as oh i
don't know
leading an assault on a kaaba
again if you've seen the movie this is
like the first half of it and that
thing's almost four hours long so
suffice to say that it was a crucial
turning point not just for lawrence's
legacy but also for the arab revolt in
case you need a quick refresher acaba
was a coastal city located on the very
northern tip of the red sea now a day
situated in jordan it had great
strategic value because it was
surrounded by mountains on two sides and
could have been used as a naval base for
german submarines and mine layers in the
red sea taking it from the front was
almost impossible because the city was
protected by a narrow gorge that would
have funneled enemy ships into cannon
range like lambs to the slaughter the
eastern flank however was not very well
protected mainly because the turks were
not expecting anyone to attack from that
direction lawrence thought that taking
acaba would have been of great
importance for his side but especially
for the arabs who would then be able to
use it as a base for conducting raids on
the damascus medina railway he actually
went against his superiors to get this
done of course the british would have
liked the city to be in friendly hands
but they kinda sort of promised it to
the french plus they did not think that
a small group of under-equipped arab
fighters would be able to occupy the
port and they probably would have been
right if not for one man aouda abu tayer
he was the leader of the hauitap tribe
and described by lawrence as the
greatest fighting man in northern arabia
while faisal might have been the
spiritual leader who inspired the arabs
alder was the warrior general who fought
alongside them and led them to victory
he was described as modest honest and
kind-hearted to his guests but a wild
beast to his enemies according to legend
oda killed 75 arabs by his own hand and
he never bothered to count the turks
because those would have been in the
hundreds the howard hat were regarded as
the finest warriors in the desert so
it's no surprise that both sides wanted
them as allies and not enemies at the
start of the revolt the howard chat were
technically on the payroll of the
ottoman empire but they weren't on
friendly terms by any stretch of the
imagination but just like with faizal
lawrence both charmed and inspired elder
to fight for the arab cause and once
elder was in he was all the way in
becoming the main military leader of the
revolt and turning down multiple offers
from the turks to switch allegiances
once more unlike the movie the real arab
force never crossed the impassable nefer
desert in order to reach acaba for a
simple reason there was no need that was
just a bit of movie magic to add more
drama in reality the army stayed on the
road by the edge of the desert attacking
several turkish garrisons along the way
when lawrence first sailed off on this
thousand kilometer two-month-long camel
trek he was accompanied by just 45 men
by the time he reached acaba in july
1917 that number had swelled to 500 and
maybe to the thousands depending on who
you ask many arabs were ready to fight
for the cause especially when it was
supported by key figures like faisal and
alder calling this the battle of acaba
is a bit disingenuous because the real
fighting actually happened at abba
el-nasan about 65 kilometers away where
the bulk of the turkish forces were
located on july the 1st the arab army
took them by surprise and decimated the
enemy killing around 300 soldiers and
taking another 300 prisoners while they
only sustained two casualties afterward
when the arabs stormed the city of acaba
the few soldiers still stationed there
only fired a few shots before officially
surrendering on july 6. it was a huge
victory for the revolt and for lawrence
personally but we should remember that
he was still an amateur archaeologist
with no military training he was merely
role-playing as a soldier and somehow
had not gotten himself killed just yet
thanks to buffs in luck and charisma and
is a perfect example of that during the
battle lawrence did not take part in the
initial charge why because he was thrown
off his camel right after the fighting
started this alone was embarrassing
enough but when laurence got up he
noticed that the reason he was thrown
off was that in all the excitement he
had accidentally shot the animal in the
back of the head
[Music]
following the success at kaaba the fact
that lawrence went against his orders
was conveniently forgotten his new boss
general edmund allenby was a fan of
lawrence's derende allenby had just been
transferred from the french front lines
by comparison the war in the middle east
was a lot more boring for the british at
least therefore he was inclined to grant
several of lawrence's requests to help
with the arab revolt the most
controversial aspect of lauren's life
happened soon after on november 20th
1917 when he was captured by turkish
guards while in dara in disguise and
subjected to beatings torture and rape
initially scholars thought this had a
great psychological effect on lawrence's
behavior and made him more reckless and
bloodthirsty but nowadays some have gone
the other way and claimed that the
officer exaggerated the event in his
book and some even accused him of making
the whole thing up whether or not it
happened in the short term lawrence did
not allow the traumatic event to get in
the way of his plans he continued to go
on recon missions in disguise and he
continued to lead raids on the military
but these were mere distractions as the
strength of the allied powers kept
growing already he saw britain and
france making plans to divvy up the
region after the war plans that only
tangentially included the local forces
he thought there was one more hope for
the arab people if they controlled one
of the major cities when it was all said
and done they would have a good
bargaining chip during negotiations he
wanted them to take damascus
unfortunately things didn't exactly go
according to plan damascus did fall on
october 1st 1918 and lawrence entered
the city triumphantly in a rolls-royce
however when he did so he was greeted by
allied units who were already inside
because it was the australians who first
captured the city and not the arabs
pretty much what lawrence expected to
happen happened a lot of bureaucratic
brujah between the various sides of who
was in charge the arabs tried setting up
a government but were forced by the
allies to accept french supervision
meanwhile lawrence's police fell on deaf
ears and when his superiors finally got
tired of him they promoted him to
colonel and sent him back home to
england and just like that lawrence of
arabia was gone once the war was over
and allied forces left the middle east
faisal tried proclaiming himself king of
the new arab kingdom of syria but none
of the allied powers recognized his
authority instead following the san remo
conference in 1920 they awarded the
mandate of syria to france this led to
the brief franco-syrian war which didn't
actually involve faisal himself as he
willingly surrendered but one of his
ministers who wasn't quite ready to
throw in the towel france easily won
dethroned faisal and established the
french mandate of syria meanwhile as a
sort of consolation prize the british
made farsal the king of iraq a position
he held until his death in 1933. back in
england lawrence got to work on writing
his book seven pillars of wisdom about
his experience during the arab revolt he
finished it in 1922 but it wasn't
published until 1926. he often expressed
his shame at what he thought as a
betrayal of the arab people and
considered himself partly responsible
for wearing a mantle of fraud throughout
the military campaign for giving them
hope when he knew the true intentions of
his government he kept trying to
advocate on behalf of the arab people
for years after the war working as a
diplomat and advisor for winston
churchill lawrence experienced newfound
fame during these years during the war
his exploits had been kept strictly
hush-hush but now everything was out in
the open it was actually an american
writer and broadcaster named lal thomas
who popularized his adventures and
turned him into a household name
lawrence wasn't too fond of being a
celebrity though once he finished his
book he tried joining the royal air
force under the assumed name of john
hume ross when he was discovered he was
discharged but then enlisted in the tank
corps under yet another name t.e shaw
after a few years he was allowed to
transfer back to the raf where he
remained until shortly before his death
he was a fan of all high-speed machines
airplanes motorcycles power boats and he
worked on them all as an aircraftman a
mechanic lawrence had his own bro
superior ss-100 motorcycle which he
dubbed george v on may the 13th 1935 he
was riding his beloved george through
dorset when he swerved suddenly to avoid
two boys on bicycles he lost control of
the motorcycle and crashed he died of
head injuries six days later on may the
19th age 46. lawrence had one last
inadvertent effect on the world one of
the doctors who attended him after the
accident was an australian man named
hugh cans who went on to become a
pioneering neurosurgeon following
lawrence's death khans was inspired to
study head trauma on motorcycle accident
victims and his research led to the
adoption of crash helmets now just
before you leave today maybe looking for
something else to watch why not check
out my new channel called wara graphics
want to know all of the details about
some of history's most famous battles
and wars come join me on war of graphics
from sherman's march to the sea to
operation barbarossa it's got people
fighting each other or occasionally
animals we will cover it there is a link
below
[Music]
you